bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 nous sommes le mardi
20 octobre voici les titres de
l'actualité locale
quatre jours après l'assassinât de
samuel pâti cette mobilisation que ce
soir à conflans sainte honorine une
marche blanche est organisée à partir de
18h30 au départ du collège du bois
d'aulne là où enseigner le professeur
d'histoire géographie et nous irons sur
place dans cette édition
l'actualité c'est aussi la deuxième
vague de kovy 19 les yvelines vous le
savez sont sous la mesure du couvre-feu
depuis le 17 octobre et pour quatre
semaines au moins un département qui a
atteint hier les 600 décès à l'hôpital
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire et
où tous les indicateurs sont à la hausse
et puis retour à la fin de ce journal
sur les journées nationales de
l'architecturé l'événement se tenait ce
week-end à saint quentin en yvelines la
gare située à montigny le bretonneux
dévoilé tous ses secrets pour l'occasion
une minute de silence observée à 14h30
par les députés en hommage à samuel
pâtit les 300 parlementaires se sont
réunis au sein de leur écharpe tricolore
sur les marches du palais bourbon 3
banderole derrière avec dessus la devise
nationale liberté égalité fraternité une
marseillaise à outils a aussi été joués
par un orchestre militaire les honneurs
se succèdent pour l'enseignant
d'histoire géographie décapité vendredi
à proximité de son collège du bois
d'aulne à conflans sainte honorine visé
pour avoir montré en classe des
caricatures du prophète mahomet le
professeur va recevoir on l'a appris ce
matin la légion d'honneur à titre
posthume annonces du ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer rcml pâtit sera également fait
commandeur des palmes académiques et
d'edx distinction qui seront remises
lors de l'hommage national prévu pour
rappel demain il se tiendra à partir de
19 heures dans la cour de la sorbonne tv
60,18 vous proposera d'ailleurs une
édition spéciale en attendant cet
hommage national nous allons tout de
suite à conflans sainte honorine devant
le collège du bois donne où se tient
tout à l'heure une marche
une marche blanche on retrouve
d'ailleurs un sur place eléonore
sinoquet de la rédaction de tv 78
bonsoir la marche va débuter le nord
d'ici quelques minutes
bonsoir et orrit en effet la marche de
conflans sainte honorine la marche
blanche en l'honneur de sa mère pattie
ce professeur assassiné comme vous
l'avez rappelé va débuter à 18h30
elle part du collège du bois d'auch
louis l'enseigné justement à ses élèves
la liberté d'expression et elle ira
jusqu'à la place de la liberté à
conflans sainte honorine
voilà ce que je peux vous dire pour
l'instant beaucoup beaucoup de monde et
sur place comme vous pouvez le voir sur
les images juste derrière moi la pluie
qui est évidemment bien présente ce soir
est énormément comme je vous disais de
monde qui s'est rassemblée pour cette
marche blanche officiel avant l'hommage
national qui lui sera rendu à la
sorbonne demain à paris avec évidemment
sa famille eléonore sinoquet depuis
conflans sainte honorine au soutien dont
vous l'avez préciser à cette marche
blanche à partir de 18h30 du monde qui
arrive pour cette marche blanche on vous
retrouvera en plusieurs fois dans cette
édition pour faire le point sur cette
marche blanche d'autres communes
du hommage hier aussi à samuel pâti dans
le reste des yvelines nous vous parlions
d'un rassemblement à montigny le
bretonneux dans l'édition spéciale
d'hier lundi soir versailles et poissy
se sont aussi mobilisés le reportage
d'astrid bergère et des lots nord s'est
moqué des personnes par centaines se
sont réunis devant la mairie de poissy
ce lundi 19 octobre après l'assassinât
de sa mère pattie la municipalité a
invité les habitants au recueillement
le souhaitions rendre hommage à samuel
pâtit mais également à l'ensemble du
corps enseignant qui chaque jour
construisez certes il y avait eu ce
drame mais qui est important pour nous
de dire les uns aux autres nous étions
ensemble en fraternité
de nombreux enseignants et
professionnels de l'éducation étaient
présents dans la foule
je suis directrice d'école sur la vie et
ça me paraissait important de rendre
hommage à un collègue qui a été
lâchement assassinés
on est horrifiée parce que quelqu'un qui
fait un métier très noble certains
diront le plus beau métier du monde
il a été exécuté dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions
donc c'est incompréhensible et voilà
c'est pour lui dire et dire à sa famille
on est là il est parti certes mais il
raisonne au coeur à versailles une
minute de silence a été observée bougies
et fleurs ont été déposées sur les
marches de l'hôtel de ville les
habitants sont venus soutenir le corps
enseignant pour soutenir la laïcité le
droit d'expression le droit à la parole
le droit à nos jeunes de vivre de
pouvoir s'exprimer de pouvoir être libre
aux femmes aux jeunes femmes aux hommes
au jeune homme
et puis surtout la liberté d'expression
de droit aux professeurs de faire leur
travail correctement sans ambiguïté sans
sens sans être offensé comme là c'est la
mairie qui est à l'origine de ce
rassemblement
il était important pour la municipalité
de témoigner de sa solidarité
pour nous c'est vraiment un beau
témoignage la solidarité des gens face à
ces crimes souvent atroce
et puis aussi la solidarité autour du
corps professoral auto des enseignants
parce que à travers sa nouvelle bâtisse
est aussi tous les enseignants qui sont
honorés tous ceux qui ont le courage
effectivement de rappeler les valeurs de
notre pays
ces deux rassemblements ont eu lieu
avant le grand hommage national prévu
mercredi 21 octobre à la sorbonne et la
question qui se pose désormais de
quelles aides a pu bénéficier le
terroriste de 18 ans dans le meurtre de
samuel pâtit ce mardi 16 personnes sont
en garde à vue dans le cadre de l'
enquête ouverte pour assassinats en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
et association de malfaiteurs
terroristes criminels parmi lesquels
cinq collégiens selon une source proche
du dossier un ou plusieurs élèves ont
désigné à l'assaillant le professeur a
priori en échange d'argent et on a
appris cet après-midi en a pris une
information de nos confrères de bfm tv
que le père de famille auteurs de la
vidéo où ils s'indignaient des
caricatures montré par l'enseignant
aurait été changée avec le terroriste
dans les jours précédant l'attentât via
la messagerie whatsapp quatre jours
après le choc les collègues de samuel
pâtit ont pris pour la première fois la
parole par le biais d'un communiqué dans
ce texte dévoilé par france télévisions
il témoigne de leur vive inquiétude face
à l'impact des réseaux sociaux qui on le
sait en jouer un rôle dans cette affaire
la rapidité avec laquelle l'information
est diffusée au plus grand nombre et son
aspect irréversible sont un véritable
fléau dans l'exercice de notre métier
alerte ses enseignants qui demandent à
exercer leur métier dans le respect de
la liberté pédagogique et en toute
sécurité
marlène schiappa la ministre délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté s'est
d'ailleurs entretenu ce matin avec les
cadres de facebook google twitter tik
tok ou encore snap chat on va retrouver
tout de suite pour une nouvelle fois
eléonore si nokia qui est depuis
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines pour cette marche blanche on le
rappelle une marche blanche qui est
prévue à partir de 18h30 et vous avez
une personne qui va participer le au
nord à cette marche à vos côtés
exactement nous sommes avec andré une
habitante depuis 54 ans de conflans
sainte honorine ses petits enfants
étaient au collège alors bon soir andré
expliquez nous pourquoi vous êtes ici
aujourd'hui à cette marche blanche
je viens d'abord pour cette horreur qui
s'est passé et comme mes petits enfants
étaient là il me devait devenir être
avec tout le monde pour compatir à cette
grosse douleur et pour vous c'était
vraiment important donc d'être ici c'est
ce que vous me disiez est ce que vous
êtes venus déposer des hommages
bien sûr je suis venu lendemain porter
des fleurs et je tenais à venir à cette
marche blanche malgré mans mon handicap
veut bien quand même et je compatis et
j'ai beaucoup de peine pour la famille
quelle a été votre réaction de savoir
les raisons pour lesquelles ça mais elle
pâtit a été assassiné pour la liberté
d'expression entre autres qu'est ce que
vous réclamez vous réagissez à ça mais
j'étais horrifiée parce que la liberté
d'expression devrait être par tout la
même on devrait pouvoir s'exprimer sans
avoir ce cette chose là et pour moi ça a
été horrible
merci andré en tout cas d'avoir été avec
nous voilà grégory comme vous pouvez
l'entendre de la colère de l'effarement
face à cet acte de barbarie ici
aujourd'hui à conflans sainte honorine
merci à leonardo puisse conflans sainte
honorine une marche blanche en l'honneur
de saluer lé pa ti va se tenir à partir
de 18h30 dans la commune au départ
d'ailleurs du collège du bois dolce et
la qu'enseignait samuel pâtit ce
professeur d'histoire géographie tués
vendredi dernier 1 pour avoir montré des
caricatures du prophète mahomet on
retrouvera un eléonore une dernière fois
à la fin de cette édition en tout cas
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire en ce
mardi soir
quatre jours après cette attaque
terroriste à conflans sainte honorine
[Musique]
mais l'actualité c'est aussi le co vide
19 avec des chiffres qui sont en
constante hausse dans les yvelines
regardez ce tableau le taux d'incidence
c'est à dire le nombre de tests positifs
pour 100000 habitants a désormais
franchi la barre des 250 8 soit une
progression de 35 points en une semaine
taux de positivité à 15,7 pour cent l
attention hospitalière se durcit en ile
de france avec plus de 54 % des lits de
réanimation désormais occuper l et 600
décès à l'hôpital depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire dans les yvelines ont
même été atteint hier 317 patients
étaient hospitalisés lundi dans les
yvelines ducobu de 19,39 toujours placé
en réanimation
face à l'épidémie chacun s'organise vous
avez vu la semaine dernière cette
décision prise par le président de la
république qui a décrété le couvre-feu
en ile de france et dans huit métropoles
françaises pour quatre semaines minimum
un couvre feu qui pourrait s'allonger à
six semaines
ce week-end plusieurs dizaines de
contrôles ont été effectués par les
forces de l'ordre
entre 21h et 6h du matin et ont donné
lieu à très peu de verbalisation au
niveau local on s'organise aussi pour
contrer l'épidémie à l'association deux
trappes ensemble on va plus loin
sensibiliser il ya quelques jours aux
gestes barrières c'était devant l'école
george sand en partenariat avec l'
agence régionale de santé
l association créée à la suite du
confinement et qui réunit une vingtaine
de mamans du quartier ville à george
sand pergaud verlaine ont offert des
masques du gel hydroalcoolique et 1 et
un goûter pour les enfants alors de cet
après-midi un quiz sur les gestes
barrières et est même proposée aux
familles on écoute la présidente
adjointe de cette association au micro
de ces diaga tsongo le bit en fait ce
serait d'avoir en fait si les gens du
quartier sont à l'aise avec les gestes
barrières pour ensuite faire d'autres
animations pédagogiques normalement
on aimerait faire une un atelier de
couture pour aider à prendre maman en
fait à faire des masques mais masque en
tissu
un atelier pédagogique autour du lavage
des mains est aussi la distanciation
social en fait ce sera en fait les
actions que nous allons mettre en place
seront en fonction des résultats qu'on
va avoir sur le micro trottoir
cette actualité a fait le tour des
médias nationaux en homme a été
violemment agressé à bord d'un bus à
elancourt part à huit personnes les
faits se sont déroulés samedi soir entre
les quartiers de la commanderie et de
lavilledieu il s'agirait d'un règlement
de comptes à première vue la bande étant
allé directement vers la victime au
moment de monter dans le bus alors que
la bande semblait vouloir remonter après
avoir après être descendu du bus le
chauffeur a accéléré pour protéger la
personne agressée l'homme de 27 ans a
été transporté à l'hôpital dans un état
critique la sûreté est d'elancourt est
en charge de cette enquête
c'était la semaine dernière la tournée
de l'apprentissage était de passage dans
les yvelines plusieurs étapes dans
différentes villes du département
carrières sous poissy poissy ou encore
mort pas où le bus s'est installé
mercredi 14 octobre
une initiative destinée aux jeunes pour
se renseigner sur l'apprentissage et des
formations en alternance nicolas landry
c'est une initiative dans le cadre du
plan de relance du gouvernement la
tournée de l'apprentissage orchestrée
par le ministère du travail s'est arrêté
à maurepas
objectif permettre aux jeunes de se
familiariser avec l'apprentissage
les jeunes n'ont pas forcément
connaissance de tous les avantages
de l'apprentissage voie surtout les
inconvénients difficulté ce n'est pas
négligeable que de trouver effectivement
le contrat d'apprentissage c'est à dire
l'entreprise qui va les embaucher c'est
aussi la méconnaissance de tous les
domaines vers lesquels ils peuvent se
tourner encore professionnels du ceap et
au masters sur des formations qui les
entoure ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on va voir le métier de prévoir si ça
nous plaît et pouvoir éventuellement
continuer ou changer un petit peu de
voix en cours de route
donc c'est vraiment le principal atout
de l'apprentissage ou re découverte des
métiers et des formations pour l'année
prochaine six jeunes du centre
d'éducation et de formation
professionnelle de villepreux ont
participé à ce rendez vous ils sont tous
en dernière année de ses api prépare la
suite de leurs études
là on a donné des informations sur la
voix très douce peut y aller pour
m'inscrire
l'enseigné du coup c'est intéressant
pour l'année prochaine faut réfléchir
tu apprends toujours des choses toujours
rendu triste et apprendre des choses et
ça fait du bien pour le cerveau je
souhaite continuer mes études j'ai fait
une formation en informatique
bien sûr si j'en trouve je trouve que
c'est un métier indispensable de nos
jours vu l'évolution de la technologie
tout sort la tournée de l'apprentissage
reste en ile-de-france prochaine étape
du 3 au 7 novembre 2020 dans le
département du val de marne en 2018 elle
a accueilli plus de 12 millions de
voyageurs et pourtant peu connaissent
cette histoire la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines était au coeur des journées
nationales de l'architecturé dans
l'agglomération elle livré tous ses
secrets à l'occasion de cet événement
qui se tenait au niveau national mélanie
poké et michael et demi d'eau nous livre
quelques-uns de ses secrets
certains la qualifient d'étonnantes
d'autres de peu esthétique la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines ne laisse pas
indifférent ouverte en 1975 elle est
l'élément pionnier du centre ville de
montigny le bretonneux
elle révélait samedi son histoire dans
le cadre des journées de l'architecturé
ce que maintenant la gare un peu changé
il ya un premier bâtiment qui avait été
construit entre les voies ferrées et la
nationale 10 donc un bâtiment érigé en
1975 et qui correspond à l'ouverture de
la gare
à l'époque c'est la ligne
le paris rambouillet qui s'arrête ici
dès 1975 par la suite la gare accueille
le rer c en 1980 et le
le bâtiment est complétée dans les
années qui suivent deux autres bâtiments
est en fait la volonté des aménageurs
était aussi en ouvrant cette gare en
1975 de rendre en quelque sorte
l'aménagement de la ville nouvelle
irréversible équipements multimodal la
gare rassemble chemin de fer gare
routière et vélostation la visite et en
écho à l'étude sur l'hyper centre un
réaménagement qui concerne aussi la ga
au coeur de ce projet décidée avec les
habitants j'habite le quartier 50 ha
j'ai participé aux réunions de travail
il ya quelques mois sur la rénovation du
quartier et donc je venais voir à ce que
l'on disait de l' architecture une gare
qui va changer un peu de visage dans des
prochaines années des travaux sont
engagés jusqu'en 2023 montant 43
millions d'euros à partir de 18h30 sur
tv 60,18 vous retrouverez justin brasier
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 cultura
vous proposera de nombreux sujets et
notamment celui ci le domaine de
dampierre en yvelines qui ouvre
exceptionnellement pendant les vacances
de la toussaint
son cabinet de curiosité c'est une sorte
de petit musée d'histoire naturelle
célia gars tsongo et eva champenois une
partie d'une mâchoire d'une baleine ou
une statue représentant le mythe
d'andromède cette petite salle fourmis
de collections d'archéologie de
botanique d'anatomie et de préhistoire
dans cette vitrine
les collections de paléontologie
des pièces rares inédite jamais présenté
au public
elle appartenait à la famille de luynes
propriétaire pendant plus de trois
siècles du château de dampierre
nous sommes dans la pièce principale qui
la grande pièce qui fait à peu près 400
mètres carrés qui entouré de vitrines et
au centre il ya des vitrines également
la majorité de la collection présente
des minéralogie dans cette pièce
ce sont d une collection de pierres de
toutes origines météorite pierres
précieuses fossiles plus de 6000
exemplaires de pierre sont présentés
dans cette salle également une
collection de zoologie on a des
fort belles collections entomologiques
reptiles poissons et aussi animaux
sauvages viennent compléter ses
collections les visites guidées se font
sur réservation maximum cinq personnes
par visite pour respecter les consignes
sanitaires
c'est vraiment une endroit qui grande
grande richesse donc toutes les pièces
soient mises en valeur on apprend
vraiment sûr sur la recherche
scientifique au 19e et même avant la
collection de pierres de minéraux est
vraiment extraordinaire
j'imaginais pas qu'il y avait autant de
choses différentes dans le monde
ce cabinet de curiosités seulement
ouvert pendant les vacances de la
toussaint une période propice pour
inviter les familles la présentation
exceptionnelle que nous avons
aujourd'hui elle se fait évidemment par
les vacances de la toussaint puisque on
recherche un peu le mystérieux et donc
là on est en plein dedans et puis aussi
elle correspond à la fin des travaux qui
ont été réalisés par le propriétaire
pour sécuriser cet espace
cette aile du château nommé el d'astrée
était en train de s'effondrer
il fallait donc là sécurisé pour sauver
la collection le billet d'entrée pour un
adulte est de 20 euros
voilà pour l'actualité locale et avant
de vous laisser on retrouve une dernière
fois depuis conflans sainte honorine
eléonore sinoquet l'honneur sinoquet
vous allez suivre dans quelques instants
cette marche blanche qui est programmé à
partir de 18h30 en hommage à samuel
pâtit cet enseignant mort à conflans
sainte honorine assassiné vendredi
dernier et vous êtes maintenant avec un
maire d'une commune yvelinoise
exactement nous sommes avec le maire de
maisons laffitte jacques myard bonsoir
en temps qui lui en tant que membre
honoraire du parlement de ce que vous me
disiez est-ce que c'était important pour
vous d'être ici aujourd'hui à conflans
pour cette marche blanche
vous savez c'est très simple c'était un
professeur d'histoire et géographie une
matière fondamentale pour l'éducation de
nos enfants
ça s'est passé à conflans sainte
honorine qui était une ville calme à
côté de maisons laffitte
je me sens concerné les mansonnien aussi
donc c'est tout à fait légitime que nous
soyons là aujourd'hui pour marquer notre
soutien
mais vous savez ce soutien il veut aller
beaucoup plus loin c'est un soutien pour
forcer les autorités à changer un
certain nombre de nos textes et à
prendre des mesures efficaces pour que
ça ne se reproduise plus
ça fait plus de trente ans que je
connais la dérive sectaire de l'intérêt
de l'islamisme intégriste ça fait 30 ans
que nous avons commis au parlement de
multiples rapports et malheureusement on
n'a pas vraiment bougé
aujourd'hui il semble que cela bouge et
je suis là aussi pour marquer cette
détermination à ce que les choses
bougent de manière qu'on arrête je
rappelle que vous êtes maire les
républicains encartés les républicains
quelles sont les mesures que vous
voudriez mettre en place qu'il faudrait
mettre en place selon vous ce sont des
mesures que l'homme est intérieure vient
d'annoncer à savoir des expulsions et
pour que les épices les expulsions
soient efficaces faut pratiquement
modifier la constitution parce que il y
a véritablement aujourd'hui un problème
à ce titre
deuxièmement il faut dissoudre des
associations et ça c'était déjà possible
avec le décret de 1936 et puis il faut
contrôler nos frontières car elles sont
poreuses et n'importe qui entre
deuxièmement il ya un problème avec le
droit d'asile
il y a donc toute une série de choses à
faire et il ne faut pas se leurrer sur
les réseaux sociaux bien sûr des propos
haineux
donc c'est une question d'effectivité et
ça c'est jouable
la loi actuelle nous le permettre mais
il faut en renforcer et ne jamais
oublier qu'en réalité c'est un problème
de franchisage d'une idéologie mortifère
qui se joue au niveau international la
france dans ce domaine là n'est pas un
havre de paix isolée elle subit
directement l'influencent mortifère de
cet islamisme radical qui est né en 1929
en egypte et qui se propage de manière
régulière et on a laissé faire merci
jacques myard pour toutes ces précisions
voici comme vous lisiez grigori en effet
nous allons suivre cette marche blanche
qui partira à 18h30
et comme vous pouvez le voir énormément
de personnes sont présentes ce soir à
conflans sainte honorine remercient lots
non sinoquet depuis conflans sainte
honorine merci également à mélanie
poquet aux moyens techniques pour cette
marche blanche à la veille je vous le
rappelle de cet hommage national prévu
demain à 19 heures dans la cour de la
sorbonne et je vous rappelle aussi que
tv 78 consacrera demain une édition
spéciale à cet hommage national voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal mer
de votre fidélité très belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]